et aujourd'hui on se retrouve pour la
suite deux manches de slips un jeu
d'horreur dans lequel je vous le
rappelle on joue un bébé qui s'est
lancée voilà alors par où faut aller à
déjà sûrement pas par là dans un premier
temps
[ __ ] mais où on est et c'est quoi ce
souvenir là ce doit être le plus gros
cauchemar de sa vie quoiqu'elle cet
endroit mieux vaut éviter de faire du
bruit et près des arbres dans une maison
est-ce que propriétaires des maisons et
l'écolo le plus psychopathe de la
planète ne vaut éviter de faire du bruit
c'est la porte quand tu l'ouvrés le fait
un bruit mais un mélange de forêt de
maisons les éléments qu'il faut être
soit des souvenirs peut-être su que nous
cherchons se trouve derrière ses racines
la rixe peut-être hop hop
ok c'est un puzzle ok donc à mon avis il
ya une pièce du puzzle la une la haine
là c'est parti là où il ya un truc et
c'est bien tu poses le haut niveau
puzzle est à moi des gages au bordel on
prend ça et de une pièce n'a pas le trop
d'armes a été créé pour un bébé qu ils
ont fait une petite marche d'escalier
pour y accéder tranquillement alors je
peux le mettre ou pas ah ah voilà on
s'applaudit l'artois alors du coup va
accéder à cet endroit avec une sorte de
peinture un peu un peu glauque
je suppose que ça c'est de l'eau ils
sont sur un pont la petite et la maman
au c'était en fait un passage secret
voilà quelqu'un mais cette chose-là
exprime là pour dire si jamais un bébé
passe ici il pourra descendre sans se
casser les jambes à moi j'avais pas de
repenser à la créature noir là qu'on a
vu au tout début du jeu on a vu deux
fois mais les deux fois on l'a vu ça
s'est très mal passé pour nous on est en
plein dans une forêt bon on n'est pas
sur le pont qui était sur table aussi
exactement à contourner tout seul voilà
surtout rester 2 est tout seul ah bah ça
sent le gros monstre des marécages là
haut j'ai vu un bruit dans l'eau n'est
pas une entrée par la wii ok j'ai
compris mes doudous ya des tiroirs dans
un arbre quoi c'est que cet endroit
j'avais vu ça dans l'histoire des arbres
mais du coup je peux passer au plat par
ici mon gars ninja bbc moi ta en fait
c'est un jeu de parcours met dans la
peau d'un bébé quoi escalade des meubles
du quotidien des chaises et tabourets
des tiroirs elle c'est super super bien
fait en tout cas
wen qui est un feu par là que je dois
aller peut-être au peut-être pas alors
ta phut âme je sais je suis bête et là
par là tout simplement hop le champi
c'est notre ami que va-t-il se passer
dans l'incroyable jeu elles montrent des
slips nadja on peut le freiner qu'on te
feront pour avoir une énième fausse une
pièce de puzzle
moi je suis là via ce qu'on retourne au
début un au nom phenom et d'autres faits
assez bon boîte mon pop up je suis
bloqué je suis content manquer mais je
suis en mode de noyade la continue alors
moi je préfère pour la tétine direction
le puzzle c'est bon l'autre côté du
tableau
cet endroit le nous attardons pas ici je
suis d'accord avec toi tu sais qui
encore une fois fait c'est à cause de
l'udc
ok la dernière pièce elle boit de l'eau
du puits est-ce qu'elle décède banon
allons-y ac en haut on a vu on a vu
quelque chose que j'aime pas trop passer
par là yes ça c'était ça a été créé pour
nous ça tellement peur qu on m'attrape
par ma part mes petits pieds là ce qui
chausse du xiii ce bébé mais non
personne m'attrape c'est des vrais pied
ou cdu nous faut c'est du faux je savais
c'est juste des chaussures [ __ ] de
traître de merde je l'aimé le plus plus
intelligent du monde la dcri a dit soif
quand même bon c'est je peux de biberons
depuis dix années actuellement donc oui
ça me fait plaisir oui montella est là
on va avoir un truc mais il ya goûté
très haut mais c'était pas un truc
mégawatts là c'était un buisson qui a
pris finalement on va devoir aller
dehors évidemment bah oui bien sûr pour
le coup là y'a vraiment mons quoi il est
l'heure d'aller au ya la pièce remonte
qu'est ce qu'elle fout là cette pièce de
puzzle [ __ ] me dites pas que cette
femme arbustes à jouer à 1 vous allez
acheter une pièce drôle puis quoi
ok c'est bon il ya un doute à prendre
s'il y avait un truc s'assortir tdc pour
vie eh ben la clé à sert à ça hopla fait
installer une porte mais tapie la clé
dans le saut au je suis caché
je sais pas où aller en plus du câble
sous-marin airbus avait été compliqué de
la repérer et des aides mois et des
teintes édile a tellement peur il fait
non non moi je suis très bien dans ton
dos saloperie sursaut sur sa mère tish
une clé ou et uccle et là y'a un dessin
cette petite merde en position foetale
tout bureau je crois qu'ils supposent
être moi et ça c'est la femme arbustres
à va trouver la solution est de
récupérer la clé voilà s'est introduit
dans une maison probablement ici qu'elle
habite donc ça c'est elle et ça c'est
moi ça marche t elle elle va arriver on
va devoir courir et puisqu'elle fait de
dix fois notre taille j'ai la clé bon et
j'ai dit quoi regardez là regardez la
elle enrage septennat présence c'est
bâclé a disparu alors je mets de chasse
et moi je me mets là comme ça je touche
du conte bien que vous pensez mais sa
taille elle doit faire du 58 quoi je
reste tapi au fond de mon tonneaux non
hélas personne mais un moment faut y
aller et ce jour est arrivé
j'ai la pression on se cache ben oui
mais moi on est perdus de ouf quoi aussi
son drôle de langue un bébé dans une
forêt son gps enfin un moment ça va
il faut être réaliste aussi l'espérance
de vie de ce gamin est les deux [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] j'suis cacher je suis
caché leur pas peur pas moi ça fait ça
on m'a appris que ce parce qu'en fait
ils pleurent mais là tu pleures pas
banon qua non au oui t'es mignon propos
étaient venus nombreux mini jeux sans
son haleine de fougères
ces champignons j'entends je me cachais
oh mon dieu oh non ça prédit tout va
bien ces trucs là elle va peut être un
caillou non je crois pas une seconde on
peut s'en aller vite
l'éveil [ __ ] de merde yes aller où on
dégage
ok il ya des bruits derrière on est
cachée on est cachée aux ailes des
justes là elle est à deux centimètres de
nous je vous sentir ses feuillages me
caresser la joue comme ça o o la liberté
la liberté j'ai dit sauvegarde non
sauvegarde pas si c'est mon sauvegarde
aléas j'ai peur qu'elle attrape pas des
pieds [ __ ] pourquoi j'ai peur de ça
c'est megan lund
on s'en va on a vaincu tous les démons
et je vous laisse l'honneur de cliquer
alizée abbas
vous pouvez pas bah oui oh mon dieu ah
oui bah du coup on a accès aux souvenirs
souvenirs souvenirs je suis là je me
weir tue moi je te oui ah mais non mais
non allez allez allez je veux accéder à
au petit objet magique donc là une sorte
de labyrinthe ou via un monstre je sais
pas où mais ya un monstre
j'insiste sur le fait qu' un monstre
comme vous pouvez le remarquer parce que
ya un monstre au ont dégagé d'ici
comment je peux passer ya de l'eau
partout mais c'est quoi ce cauchemar
quoi même quand j'aurai 70 ans je serai
pas de cauchemars pareil le seul gamin
il a déjà deux ans et demi fait un
cauchemar mais plus développés c'est pas
possible quoi ça un g10 choix c'est par
là j'ai trouvé la plage
il est là il est là regardez on regarde
regarde quand on regarde pas bonjour
temps je t'aime maman maman tu arrives
ma petite maman tu es la seule femme que
j'aime dans ma vie ce qui est un peu
normal vu que j'ai deux ans et demi mais
auchan faut regarder regardez voici
jambes ces affreuses jambes elles
s'épuisent même pas les feuilles au
[ __ ] mais
c'est même tu vas pas te coucher sur des
pans entiers tada ya le meuble qui
bloque saloperies le prochain souvenir
oui oui oui ça lui demande son cadeau je
me casse
ah c'est ton livre écoute il n'avait pas
beaucoup creusé qui se met à pleuvoir
vite sort nous aurons encore des ennuis
tu vois un petit lapin sort de terre ah
oui maman je me sens si bien à tes côtés
et hop je prends le libre à maman tu
pourrais pas rester ne serait-ce qu'une
fois et toboggan l'a bien mérité il est
bien ce petit jeu 1 à les fractures
ouvertes nickel je suis soulagée d'être
de retour
ah bah moi aussi des défis tarde
décidément jamais peur qu'il arrive
quelque chose pour inciter dit décidée
au rejet j'avais fait un monstre pareil
alors là non plus un homme fut gers
comme assez rare alors on devrait pas
avoir à supporter tout ça teddy sa
nouvelle maison
nan t'as pas envie un [ __ ] je t'ai dis
tu arrêtes s'est plus jamais les
frayeurs comme ça oui je sais c'est dit
il faut mettre ça là dedans puis ça fait
mais le voilà ensuite on ferme à les
cinquièmes structure encore un de
trouver et là il ya le son qui déchire
les oreilles
tu vas bien n'hésitez pas à me sers dans
tes bras si tu en as besoin oui te dis
oh mais tu n'as pas été dit il nous en
manque plus qu'un ballon adieu adieu
et c'est parti pour le dernier souffle
et voler les gens c'est déjà la fin de
cette deuxième vidéo sur mon vieux slip
j'espère que vous aura plu c'est qu'il
ya des décès car si c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo certains
venant plaisir on se retrouve très vite
pour la suite
et sûrement la fin du jeu tient tout le
monde et ça
il
c'est